[WRITING ON CHALKBOARD]
PROFESSOR: Good morning.
I think I'll start even though
people are not quite all here,
because it's time.
Sorry, I'd hoped to start
Chapter 10 last time, but
we'll start it this time.
When Ashish comes, we'll have
handouts for Chapter 10, the
new problem set and the
old problem set
solutions as usual.
This chapter is about trellis
diagrams for block codes.
Binary linear block codes of
the kind that we've seen
before, it's actually a much
more general notion that
applies to --
well, linearity is important,
although we don't see it very
specifically in the
trellis diagram.
But we'll see that for
constructing a unique minimal
trellis, linearity is
an important aspect.
Or more generally, it's just
the group property of codes
that allows us to
construct unique
minimal trellis diagrams.
And I think it's best
to motivate this
chapter by an example.
Here's a nice example of a code
that we know very well.
It has a nice trellis diagram.
It's the 8, 4, 4 Reed-Muller
code.
Just to remind you of how we
construct this code, or one of
the methods.
We have many methods.
We take this kind of universal
eight by eight --
well, it's a list
of eight tuples.
And it's the tensor product
of this little
matrix three times.
And if we create this, we get a
matrix that looks like that.
And we just pick the rows that
have weight four or greater,
and they are the generators of
the 8, 4, 4 Reed-Muller code.
So we'll take those as our
set of generators.
It's the 16 code words generated
by these four
generators here.
This goes back to the first part
of the term, but I hope
you recall that fairly
quickly.
Now I'd like to draw a trellis
diagram for this code.
I don't particularly
know why yet.
One idea I might have in mind
is to do a Viterbi algorithm
decoding as a maximum likelihood
decoding algorithm
for this code.
So let's see if I can
come up with an
efficient trellis diagram.
That means one that first
of all has really
few states in it.
Relatively few branches would be
efficient as a decoding map
for the Viterbi algorithm.
And here's a very nice one.
This looks sort of
like a rate 1/2
four-state trellis diagram.
Of course, it's not
time-invariant, doesn't go on
forever like for a convolutional
code, for a
block code.
Block code only exists
over a finite time.
So we're going to get a block
trellis that starts at a
particular time, that
ends at a particular
time in a single state.
But we want the basic
property that the --
the paths in this trellis are
in one-to-one correspondence
with the words in the code.
So, how many words are
there in the code?
There are 16 in this code.
How many paths are there
through this trellis?
Well, again it has a very
regular structure.
There is a four-way
branch here.
Wherever you get to, you have
a two-way branch here.
You have a two-way
branch here.
You have no choice here.
So there are 16 possible ways
to get through this trellis,
16 trajectories if you like.
And next let's check if they
correspond to all the possible
code words.
Here is the all 0 code
word up here.
What's next?
Let's check for the
generators.
Here is one of the generators,
1, 1, 1, 1, 0, 0, 0, 0.
And it's a 1, 1, 0, 0.
This is 1, 1 also.
1, 1 --
no, I'm sorry.
1, 1, 0, 0, 1, 1, 0, 0.
That's right.
That's this one going
through here.
And 1, 0, 1, 0, 1, 0, 1, 0.
That's here.
And what's the last one?
All ones.
Well, that's up here too.
The all one path.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How did you know
whether to make the
[INAUDIBLE] procedure?
PROFESSOR: I had side
information.
A genie told me.
I know that this is an
efficient trellis.
Where we'll get to, and I hope
today in this lecture, is a
turn-the-crank method of
constructing not only a
trellis, but the minimal
possible trellis.
So you'll be able to see how
starting from a set of four
generators like this, turn the
crank, and I'll produce a
trellis for you.
But of course you don't
see that yet.
I just know that this
is a trellis,
and it's a nice trellis.
It has nice, regular
structure.
You could decode this with a
Viterbi algorithm, and you
could see the complexity would
be comparable to the
complexity of decoding
a rate 1/2 four-state
convolutional code.
And in fact, you remember I
compared our example rate 1/2
four-state convolutional code
which had a coding gain of 4
dB with this code saying they
roughly have the same
complexity.
And when I said that, this is
what I had in mind, that I
could decode each of them with
a Viterbi algorithm with
approximately the same
amount of complexity.
And unfortunately this only has
a nominal coding gain of 3
dB, and an effective
coding gain of
slightly less than that.
So it's not quite as good as
the convolutional code.
And at the end of the day, we're
going to find out that
that's kind of typical of a
comparison between block and
convolutional codes of the
same trellis complexity.
But on the other hand, this is
certainly a better way to
decode this code, recursive by
the Viterbi algorithm, than to
do a full maximum likelihood
decoding of all 16 code words,
which involves just brute force
computing the distance
to 16 code words.
This is if you like a more
organized way of performing
the computation of how far is
the receive sequence from each
of the 16 code words.
So the reason we look for
trellises of block codes is
first of all, it's better
than exhaustive
maximum likelihood decoding.
It is a maximum likelihood
decoding algorithm since we're
going to find that we can
construct a trellis for any
linear block code, which at
worst, it's never going to be
more complicated than just
enumerating all the code words
and doing exhaustive maximum
likelihood decoding.
And usually, as in this case,
it's going to be a more
efficient method of doing
maximum likelihood decoding.
So we will have a general method
of maximum likelihood
decoding that is more
efficient than
the exhaustive method.
Secondly, there's
an interesting
link to system theory.
I won't make a great deal
of this in this course.
But what are we really
doing here?
We're representing a block code
as a finite state system.
In fact, a linear block code
is a finite state linear
system, although again the
linearity is not terribly
transparent from this picture.
So we have a linear finite state
system, just as we did
for the convolutional code.
However, it's necessarily
time varying.
It couldn't possibly be shift
invariant because we only have
a finite time axis,
if you like.
Time axis only goes over four
time units in this particular
picture, where I've grouped
two outputs at a time.
So that's interesting, and for
our purposes an interesting
aspect of this is that we now
get a notion of how complex is
a block code.
So far we've been focused on
parameters like n, k, d, which
are all algebraic parameters
of the code itself.
But we really want to know
about performance versus
complexity.
So how complex is
the 8 4 4 code?
Well, now we have a little
bit of a handle on it.
We can say its complexity is
that of a four-state machine.
So trellis complexity gives us a
measure of the complexity of
a block code so that we can,
for instance, say the
Reed-Muller codes tend to be
less complex than PCH codes.
And I'll try to give
some substance to
that as we go along.
So we get additional parameters
that have more to
do with what we really care
about, which is decoding
complexity.
And finally, I introduce this
subject because it's a
stepping stone to where we're
really going, is this notion
of codes on graphs, which is the
underlying concept for the
capacity-approaching codes
that is our goal point.
Our whole goal in this course
is to get to capacity,
specifically on the additive
white Gaussian noise channel.
And the way that people have
found they get to capacity
turbo codes, low-density
parity check codes, the
underlying concept that I'm
going to be framing that in is
codes on graphs.
And this is kind of a code on
a very elementary graph.
So it's a good way from
here to there.
So that's why we're taking
a little time to
look at this subject.
Even though as I say, at the
end of the day, even though
there's a better way of decoding
block codes than the
ways we've had previously, and a
better non-algebraic way, it
still is not going to turn out
to be as good as convolutional
codes, which we already
know about.
Any questions on what
we're doing,
motivation and so forth?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
convolutional codes is that
each node doesn't have two
things coming on to it?
PROFESSOR: That's right, it's
a little bit more irregular,
and this trellis section
doesn't look the same.
We had a completely mixing
trellis section for the
convolutional code.
This kind of divides it into two
halves which don't meet.
This basically expresses the
code as a certain subcode, and
its coset is down here.
So, it's not quite the same.
Looks different.
Maybe this will turn out
to be interesting.
Good observation.
Anything else at this point?
AUDIENCE: You just said
that this is not a
convolutional code.
Or maybe we can have more than
one states, and it is a
convolutional code.
PROFESSOR: Let's see, it's
not a convolutional code.
It's not even a terminated
convolutional code, because it
doesn't have the simple
shift register
type of trellis diagram.
At least it's not the kind
of convolutional
code we know about.
But why should it be?
Let's open up our minds
to more possibilities.
We don't really care.
The objective that we have in
mind here is we're just going
to try to come up with the most
efficient trellis picture
that we can for block code.
And we're going to use the
linearity, and we're going to
basically try to find
as few states as
possible at each time.
That's going to be our measure
of efficiency.
That's not the only one you
could think of, but it'll turn
out that any notion of efficient
representation comes
down to the same thing.
So we'll focus on a minimal
state representation of a
block code, and you can think
of this as an exercise in
system theory and minimal
realizations of a linear system.
This you can view.
A set of all 16 code words you
can view is the set of
possible trajectories of a
linear system on a time axis
of length 8, and we want to find
a minimal realization,
minimal state realization
of that linear system.
So that'll make sense to some
of you, and it won't make an
awful lot of sense to
the rest of you.
So we're after a minimal, in the
state sense, minimal state
complexity, let's say.
And let's continue to focus on
this example, and let's focus
on a particular time.
Let's focus on the halfway
point here.
Where do the state times
occur, by the way?
They occur between
the symbol tags.
You can think of a state as
being associated with a cut
between a certain set of symbols
which we call the past
and another set of symbols
which we call the future,
again using just some theoretic
temporal language.
So if we make a cut --
let's say I do it over here.
States are based on cuts between
a past and a future,
so the state actually occurs
between the fourth and the
fifth symbol here, not at either
of them, if you want to
draw where is the stated time.
And let's start with
this example.
And let's ask if we could find
any simpler trellis for this.
In other words, let's see if
we can have fewer than four
states at this midpoint.
Could we possibly have
fewer than four
states at the midpoint?
What's the key property
of states?
The key property of states is
that once you get to a state,
that then becomes a summary of
all the history that you know
about the past, and any past
sequence or partial sequence
that gets you to this state has
to have the same set of
possible continuations over here
in the future in order
for this to be a valid trellis
representation.
So maybe it will help if I draw
this just focusing on the
central time.
There are two ways to get
to this central time.
One is to get to what
we call the 0 state.
We can get there by 0, 0,
0, 0 or 1, 1, 1, 1.
There's a second state which
we can get to again by two
paths, which are 0, 0,
1, 1 or 1, 1, 0, 0.
There's a third one, which we
can get to by 1, 0, 1, 0 or
its complement, 0, 1, 0, 1.
We'll see that each of these
involves a four-tuple and its
complement.
And this is 1, 0, 0,
1 or 0, 1, 1, 0.
Those are the set of possible
past sequences that can get to
any of these four states.
There are two of them.
Now what this trellis says
is that from this state,
regardless of how we got here,
either of these two things,
there are two possible
continuations, which happen to
be the same thing.
And the property state has to
be that either of these
continuations is a legitimate
continuation of either of the
paths that it takes
to get there.
So we now have four possible
code words that go through
this particular state, that
pass through this state.
And down here, similarly, I
think what we have is the same
set of code words.
There's complete symmetry
and so forth.
Let's ask, could we combine
these two states, somehow
smush them together into
a single state?
And the answer is obviously no,
because 0, 0, 1, 1 is not
a continuation of the
all 0 sequence, or
of the all 1 sequence.
And 0, 0, 0, 0 is not a
continuation of the 0, 0, 1, 1
sequence or the 1,
1, 0, 0 sequence.
The property of the state
is the Markov property.
And there are many ways of
phrasing this, but this is the
defining property of states, is
that if two past paths have
a future continuation --
I hope you understand this
language as I introduce it --
in common, then all
their future
continuations are in common.
So I have two past
paths, let's say.
This is the definition
of states.
If we can find such a situation,
then we can say
that these two past paths go
through the same state at the
cut time, because then we
can smush them together.
You can think of this as our
starting from, but suppose we
drew all 16 code words,
and we drew a --
here would be a 16 state
trellis, and the first two
elements of it might be 0, 0,
0, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1.
And we'd ask, can we smush these
two states together?
And the answer is yes because
of this property, because 0,
0, 0 can also be followed
by 1, 1, 1, 1.
There are actually four
states that we're
smushing together here.
1, 1, 1, 1 and 0, 0, 0.
These are all legitimate code
words, and because they're all
legitimate, we can basically
break this up into a Cartesian
product of two paths with two
futures, and represent all
four of them by a
single state.
So that's what states do.
If we want a minimal state
diagram, we should do this as
much as possible.
It's not very well-defined right
now, but we should merge
states wherever this
property holds.
So this implies they go through
a common state, and
it's if and only if.
So you could see it
very concretely
from the trellis diagram.
This is the property
that we need.
You can see that for this
particular code, we do have
the possibility of combining
all 16 possible states here
into 4, because we can
combine them all
pair-wise in this way.
This is going to come from the
linear property of the code.
That's why everything
is so symmetric.
But we can't go any
further than that.
So we can conclude from this is
that for the 8, 4, 4 code,
the minimal state space
at the center has four
states, has size four.
For simple code like this, you
can simply see what all the
possibilities are, and this
is the best we can do.
So do you get that?
This is fundamental
system theory
state realization theory.
I don't know where
in the curriculum
one gets this nowadays.
Probably somewhere over towards
the control side,
maybe in digital signal
processing, but maybe not.
But we're doing system
theory here.
We all get that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
properties basically defined, I
have two possible paths, and
they have one common
[INAUDIBLE]
data, they have [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, if they go
through a common state, that
implies this statement.
Conversely, if we have a set of
past paths and future paths
that have this property, then
we can define a state.
In other words, states are
always going to look something
like this, with a set
of past paths.
We have a set of future paths,
and the state is simply a node
that they go through such that
you can combine any of these
paths with any of
these futures.
If it's symmetric, you could
say the same thing.
If two futures have a past in
common, then they have all
their paths in common.
But whenever you have a state
representation --
let's suppose we have
three states there.
Then this is what, just looking
at those states and
the initial and final states,
this is what the code is going
to have to look like.
Because property of state is
that however you got there,
you have to be able to take
any of these over here.
Otherwise the trellis
is invalid.
If not all of these nine
sequences are code words, then
it's not a valid trellis
representation, or
equivalently, it's not a valid
state representation.
So if, and only if, we
can draw the thing in
this way, we get it.
So for a small code, you can
just see how much combining
you can do.
In particular, you can ask,
what can the 0, 0 state --
0, 0 path sequence -- what can
that be combined with?
Well, it can only be combined
with sequences that have a 0
first part.
So let me introduce now
the idea of subcodes.
We have a linear code C. Let's
define an interval on the time
axis: k, k prime, whatever.
The subcode C on that interval
is the set of all code words.
Elegant way to say it is whose
support is in k, k prime.
In other words, which are all
0 outside, which have all 0
symbols outside of this
interval that we've
identified.
So that's just notation.
So specifically, let's say the
past code with respect to a
certain time, like the
midpoint there.
Well, we can define that as the
set of all code words that
are 0 outside the past, the
first four symbols, and we
define the future subcode as the
set of all code words that
are 0 outside the future.
For this code, what is that?
We list the 16 code words.
We make this the past.
We make this the future.
What is the past subcode here?
In this particular case, the
past subcode is, of course,
the all 0 sequence.
It was always in this code
or this sequence,
1, 1, 1, 0, 0, 0.
It's a linear code of dimension
one, and it consists
of these two code words.
It is precisely the set of all
code words that can be
followed by the all
0 sequence.
So I can read it directly off of
this trellis picture here.
So everybody with me?
The past subcode just consists
of those two words.
The future subcode consists
similarly.
Looking at the trellis, it's the
1's that are all 0 outside
the future.
In other words, can follow
a past which is all 0.
In other words, it's these
two code words.
So here are two little
subcodes with a code.
So by definition, this is
subcode of C. If C is linear,
you can quickly convince
yourself this is a linear
subcode, so it's going to have
a certain dimension.
It's going to have size equal
to a power of two.
It's even going to have a
minimum distance that is at
least as great as the minimum
distance of C, because it
consists of code words of C, so
its minimum non-zero weight
is going to be at least as great
as that of C. So it has
some properties immediately.
These past and future codes seem
to have a lot to do with
the structure of the
trellis up here.
In fact, the zero state consists
of precisely --
the sequences that go through
the zero state here are not
coincidentally the set of all
past code words in Cp followed
by the set of all future
code words in Cf.
And why is that?
It's because the set of all
ways of getting to here,
getting to this state, have
to be the set of all code
sequences that can be followed
by the all 0 sequence.
Similarly, the set of all
continuations from this state
have to be the set of
all continuations
of the all 0 sequence.
So the zero state is always
going to be a little
sub-trellis that is going to
represent in effect --
you can draw it as a sum, or
a product, of the past and
future subcodes.
In other words, there's a
two-dimensional code that has
these two generators.
g1, g2 generates a little
two-dimensional code.
Here's the fourth code word in
it, the all 1 code sequence.
And every element in that
two-dimensional code goes
through the zero state.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
code word.
So then you know --
PROFESSOR: It's whatever
it happens to be.
AUDIENCE: Then you have a
separate state just for --
you could combine them.
PROFESSOR: It doesn't matter.
Suppose that Cp has
dimension one.
Cf has dimension one.
That means Cp is going to
be something like this.
Cf is going to be something
like this.
Whatever, what way.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It just follows
from linearity.
And clearly, since C itself was
linear, we're allowed to
add x, x, x, x all 0's
to y, y, y, y.
That's a code word, because
these were both code words in
C. So the linearity allows you
to fill in this fourth corner
of the rectangle, if you like.
So Cp plus Cf is always going
to look like this.
And we'll always call this the
zero state, the state that you
get to by the all 0 sequence.
And that can be followed
by the all 0 sequence.
That's always going to be
called the zero state.
By linearity, it's always
going to look like that.
It might not be dimension one.
It could have any
dimension here.
So we're really beginning
to get somewhere now.
What do all these other states
look like, grouped
theoretically?
Cosets.
Somebody -- who said cosets?
Good, that's right.
So Cp plus Cf is itself
a subcode of C, a
two-dimensional subcode.
So there are four cosets of Cp
plus Cf in C, and we'll see if
they correspond to
the four states.
So how do we do this
algebraically?
Let's draw a generator matrix
for C in a certain form.
Again, I'll draw the
past, the future.
So that's the only division I'm
concerned with right now.
And let me draw it in
general form first.
I've defined this past subcode,
Cp, at a certain
dimension, so it has a certain
number of generators.
So we're going to put up here a
set of generators for Cp, g
of Cp, however many there
happen to be.
And what's their common
characteristic?
They all are all 0
in the future.
So they're all going
to look like that.
Then I'm going to take a set
of generators of Cf, and
similarly I'm going to use
them up over there.
These are all code words, and
they're clearly linear and
independent of those.
So I'm on my way to constructing
a generator
matrix for C.
But obviously I'm going
to need some more.
We can call this the number of
generators in the past, the
number of generators
in the future.
This is the dimension of Cp.
This is the dimension of Cf.
And now I need some more
generators, which by
definition are going to have to
span both past and future.
Let's see.
Since I've already introduced
the coset language, let me
just mysteriously put that
as the generators
of a quotient group.
C mod Cp and Cf is what that
means, and it's a quotient
group, if you know or recall
what a quotient group is.
But anyway, there are k minus
kp minus kf of these.
And I don't particularly care
what I put down in here.
Their property is that
they have to span
both past and future.
So for our particular example,
here's the generator for the
8, 4, 4 code.
What we're talking about is
a generator that looks
like 1, 1, 1, 1.
That's k past is 1.
0, 0, 0, 1, 1, 1, 1.
k future is 1.
They're both one-dimensional
codes.
Now I need two other generators,
which must span
past and future.
So what'll I take?
Let me just take two more.
1, 1, 0, 0, 1, 1, 0, 0, 1,
0, 1, 0, 1, 0, 1, 0.
That would be one
possible choice.
And so this is k minus kp
minus kf, which is 2.
What I'm going to claim is that
I'm going to need a state
for every possible linear
combination of these
generators.
So claim --
well, let me break it down into
more logical sequence.
Every code word in C can be
written as some linear
combination of the generators.
What does that amount to?
It amounts to a certain code
word in the past code plus a
certain component in the future
code, either all 0 or
they're all one, plus --
let me call this the state code,
S, as I do in the notes.
So in this case we have a
two-dimensional state code.
Its elements are eight-tuples.
It's just a subcode of the code
we started with, so it's
not quite clear how it
corresponds to states yet.
Well, let me just call that
S for state sequence.
And I claim I can break this up
because the proof is that
for every c in C is equal
to a sum of --
it's a linear combination
of the generators.
So I just break that up into
the three possible parts.
So I get one part that's in the
past subcode, one part's
in the future subcode, and
one is in the state.
So this is the past, this is the
future, this is the state.
So I just break it up
according to this.
So the 16 code words can all be
written in this way in our
particular example.
So let's project this code
word on the past.
What does projection mean?
It means you just don't
look at the part
that's in the future.
So we're looking at
four-tuples now.
So C projected on to the
past, this is the part
that lives over here.
It is equal to -- well, if I
project the past code word on
the past, I basically get the
past code word again.
Let me write it like that, but
it's a little bit redundant.
Incidental comment: I can regard
this past subcode as
either an 8 1 4 code, but
what is it really?
It doesn't live out here.
It's support is on these four.
It's really a 4 1 4 repetition
code that lives on the past.
It's support is the past.
Similarly, the support here
is the future, and it's
effectively a 4 1 4 repetition
code for our example.
But formally, if we project
this on the past, it's a
one-to-one projection.
What happens to the
future part?
This disappears, because the
projection of anything in the
future code on the past is
all 0 by definition.
Plus, it's the projection
of the state
sequence on the past.
Could the projection of
the state sequence on
the past be all 0?
This is actually an
important point.
Could the the projection of
any linear combination of
these generators down here
be all 0 in the past?
The answer is no by
the definition
of the future subcode.
If I found a linear combination
of this that was
all 0 in the past, I should add
that to the generators of
the future subcode.
So by defining this in this way,
I've forced this to be
nonzero, unless, of
course, the state
sequence itself was 0.
The all 0 sequence is
in the state code.
So this is nonzero
if S is nonzero.
And similarly, if I project
a code word on the
future, I get --
this becomes all 0.
I get the element of the future
code projected on the
future, plus the state on the
future, the state projected on
the future.
And now I claim further that
this means I can draw a
trellis as follows.
Start from here.
For the all 0 sequence, I'll
have a bunch of parallel paths
going to the zero state
that together add
up to the past subcode.
These are precise.
One of these is going to be all
0, and these are precisely
the ones over here that can be
followed by all 0, as I've
already claimed.
So these are the ones that
can be followed by 0, and
similarly over here I'm going to
put all the future subcode.
I will say these correspond
to the state sequence 0.
These are the ones where if I
put 0 coefficients down here,
I just get linear combinations
of the past subcode and the
future subcode.
I'm going to write those
as going through
all one trellis state.
And I believe I've already made
the argument that this
state at least is legitimate,
that every combination of
something in the past subcode
with something in the future
subcode is a code word.
This is simply just Cp plus
Cf, what I wrote before.
So I've got one state that
represents all of Cp plus Cf.
And now let's take another
typical state down here.
We'll say this state corresponds
to the state
sequence S, or S is a general
state sequence.
Think of it as being nonzero.
And what am I going
to put on that?
I'm going to put Cp plus
this state sequence
projected on the past.
And that way I'll get all past
projections that are of this
form for a specific S projected
on the past,
allowing this to vary through
the past subcode.
And similarly over here, I will
let the set of all these
trellis branches be
Cf plus the state
projected on the future.
So all the things that go
through this state here will
be Cp plus Cf plus this
particular state sequence.
So for each of the state
sequences, I claim I can
define a state.
So it's the set of all past
continuations of anything that
projects on the past as anything
in the past subcode
plus a past projection of the
state sequence can be combined
with anything in the future,
Cf plus the future
continuation of the
state sequence.
One of these is simply the past
projection of the state
sequence plus the future
projection
of the state sequence.
And this is S, and by
construction this is a code
word in the code.
Now by linearity I can add any
past code word to this past
projection.
And that's a code word, so any
of these elements plus Sf,
continued by Sf, the future
projection is a code word.
See, there we're taking
something generated by Cp and
the state code.
And similarly, anything by
here comes out here.
So I think I've left one or two
details undone, but are
you convinced that I can define
a state in this way
such that all of these pasts can
be followed by all these
futures, and they're
code words?
In fact, they correspond
to this subset of
elements of the code.
We have examples
of it up here.
For instance, 0, 0, 1, 1.
Or let's see.
Let's take a past protection,
1, 1, 0, 0.
Here's a typical state
sequence, 1, 1,
0, 0, 1, 1, 0, 0.
And I can add to this anything
in the past, so I get 0, 0, 1,
1, 1, 1, 0, 0.
I can add to it any of these
two, anything in the future.
So I get 1, 1, 0, 0, 0, 0, 1, 1
and 0, 0, 1, 1, 0, 0, 1, 1.
And I claim that all four of
these have the state projected
on the past equals 1, 1, 0, 0.
The state projected on the
future is 1, 1, 0, 0.
And that any of these pasts
can be followed by any of
these futures.
So this is C past plus
C future plus 1, 1,
0, 0, 1, 1, 0, 0.
That is the claim.
And furthermore, if I go through
this, dot dot dot, I'm
going to generate everything in
C. So this is the partition
of C -- into what?
S cosets of Cp plus Cf,
subcode of C. So
algebraically, that's
what's going on.
But having done this partition,
at least with
respect to this state space, I
can create something which has
S states the size of
S, which is --
what is this?
The dimension of S is the
dimension of C minus the
dimension of Cp minus
the dimension of Cf.
So I've argued that
I can get a state
space with this dimension.
It's a linear state space, and
it has a certain dimension,
which is just the dimension of
C minus the dimension of the
past subcode minus
the dimension
of the future subcode.
It's the number of generators
that I need for S. So in the
example, I need two generators
for S, so I get a state space
of dimension two,
or size four.
It's just a vector space
over F2 in this case.
You all with me?
I think you are.
I don't see any great puzzles.
So I can get at least
these few states.
Could I get any fewer?
Can I possibly merge any
two of these states?
Could I draw a trellis in which,
say, I've mushed the
zero state together with one
of these nonzero states?
And the answer to that is
clearly no by the definition
of the past and the
future subcodes.
These are all of the future
sequences that can follow the
all 0 past sequence.
There can't be any more down
here, so we can't possibly
mush them together.
And similarly, just by going
through this, if you can't
take the past part of one state
and combine it with a
future part of another state
sequence, because that clearly
is not in the code.
And I don't have a slick proof
of that in mind at the moment,
but there is one in the notes.
The conclusion from this
is what I call
the state space theorem.
Given code C, any partition of
the time axis, the total index
set, into past and future,
I can do this
not just at the midpoint.
I can do this any point along
the code that I want to, any
partition into past
and future.
The minimal --
we get a linear state space, in
other words a vector space,
S. And the dimension of S is
equal to the dimension of C
minus the dimension of this
past subcode minus the
dimension of the
future subcode.
So we can simply calculate what
the minimal dimension of
a state space is at any
point along here.
So for instance, at this point
here, what's the minimal size
of a state space?
What's the past subcode here?
What's the set of all code
sequences that are all 0 in
the future, as we have
all 0's out here?
This point, Cp, is just 0, 0.
It just has dimension 0.
Yeah, 0
What's the future subcode?
This is the subcode which has
support all out here.
This is anything that
starts with 0, 0.
This is 0, 0, 0, 0, 0,
0, 0, 1, 1, 1, 1.
Let me just write
down generators.
1, 1, 1, 1, 0, 0.
So there is -- this is dimension
Cp equals 0.
Dimension Cf equals 2.
And so the minimum size of the
state space is 4 minus 2.
That's again 2.
AUDIENCE: Does this mean
that [INAUDIBLE]
each state's the number
of states is the same?
PROFESSOR: Certainly not
true in general.
Let me ask about time three.
Can certainly do that.
Time three, what's
the past subcode?
This is the code words that
have support on the first
three symbols.
Again, that has to have
dimension 0, because the
minimum weight of
this code is 4.
So there can't be anything that
just looks like 1,1,1 and
then five 0's
What is the future
subcode for that?
Now the only generator
of the future subcode
is 0, 1, 1, 1, 1.
We have to go this far, and then
it's what futures can we
get from here?
There are only two words
that are in the future.
So in that case we have
dimension past is 0.
Dimension future is 1.
So if we drew a state space
here, we would have to have
eight states.
In fact, I can do that if I just
draw a little state in
the middle of each
of these lines.
I get now a trellis picture
which has an explicit state at
this third time here, but
it has eight states.
Oo ugly, so I've masked that.
I've suppressed that
by this nice
little four-state trellis.
But yeah, if you insisted on
drawing a state space at time
three, it would have
eight states in it.
We'll get back to that when I
get to this turn-the-crank
procedure, if I do, of getting
to minimal trellises.
So what have we done?
We've established that there is
a uniquely defined minimal
state space size for
any partition
between past and future.
In other words, if there's any
time where you want to make a
cut in the time axis between
past and future, you can
define what the minimal
state space size is.
And now you might ask
the question, can we
simultaneously achieve minimal
state spaces at all times?
In other words, can we draw a
single trellis which gets the
minimal state space
at each time?
We haven't proved
that there is.
It might be that if you push
in the state space at one
time, it forces the state
space to balloon out at
another time.
And in fact, for nonlinear
codes, that is
typically what happens.
But for linear codes, a
minor miracle occurs.
And the answer is yes.
So how am I going
to prove that?
I'm going to prove it via this
very handy tool, which is also
a construction tool which is
called a trellis-oriented, or
a little bit more formally, a
minimum span generator matrix.
The idea here is, given a
generator matrix, reduce to
trellis-oriented form.
We're going to prove that this
is unique, or effectively
unique, and specifies minimal
trellis at all times in a
certain way.
Let's start again.
So loosely, what is a
trellis-oriented generator matrix?
Well, if we have a generator,
say 0, 0, 1, 1, 1, 1, 0, 0,
its span is this interval from
its starting time to its
ending time.
It's this.
We say it starts at time 3, it
ends at time 6, the span is
the interval 3 to
6 in this case.
So we think of this as not being
active before time 3.
At time 3 we get the first
interesting thing happens.
A 1 comes up, but then goes
through something.
These don't have
to all be ones.
It could be 1, 1, 0, 1.
Then there's a last 1 at some
point, and then it quiets
down, and it's dead again.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Except I'm not sure.
Would you say the support of
this was 3, 4, and 6, or would
you say it was the interval
from 3 to 6?
I don't know.
What's the definition
of support?
AUDIENCE: I don't know it.
PROFESSOR: I'm not
sure I know.
It's probably been defined
both ways in different
literatures.
So I'll call it a span, but it's
roughly the support of
the interesting part.
So that's the definition
of span.
And what a trellis-oriented
general matrix is, a
minimal-span matrix, meaning all
generators have a short a
span as possible.
I'll just say, are as
short as possible.
This is a lecture.
I can be loose.
Now it's not even clear that's
well-defined yet.
But let me again give you an
example, and show you how to
find a trellis-oriented
generating
matrix just by example.
Let me take our example here, 1,
1, 0, 0, 1, 1, 0, 0, 1, 0,
1, 0, 1, 0, 1, 0, 1,
1, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1.
So there is a generator
matrix that's not in
trellis-oriented form.
In particular, I can see that by
adding this to this, I can
make this generator
have shorter span.
I can replace it by one, which
is four 0's and then four 1's,
which we've already
found useful in
constructing a trellis.
But let me proceed through
it more systematically.
How can I make --
this generator generates
all words in the code.
So how can I find a set of
linearly independent
generators that has
shorter span?
There's the sort of greedy
way of proceeding.
Let's take the first
two generators.
Can I combine these to find
anything that has a shorter
span, that I can replace one
of the generators with?
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No, I can't.
That's not the answer
I expected to hear.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Let's identify what
the spans of these are.
That has a span of four.
That has a span of six.
That has a span of seven.
This has a span of eight.
What I'm trying to do
is to reduce that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So if I add the first
two, that seems like a
good thing to do, because then
I get 0, 0, 1, 1, and I've
reduced the span of
that generator.
Any way I can combine these
two to reduce the span?
Obviously not, because the span
of this is completely
included in the span of this.
If I add these two together,
then I'll get something which
still starts here
and ends here.
Why was I able to reduce
the span here?
Because the spans had the same
starting time, so I got a
cancellation of the first bit.
I got a 0 up here.
That's what I wanted.
So that's the key
to proceeding.
If I see any place, any two that
have the same starting
time, then I can add them
together, and the result will
be something that has a
shorter span than at
least one of them.
So let me do that.
I see two here that have the
same starting time, and so I
add that to that, and
I get 0 1 0 1.
So I've got the span
down to here.
I can do that down here.
And I get this, which is a very
nice reduction in span.
Can I go any further?
I can clearly look for the same
thing in ending times, if
I could find two ending times
that were the same.
I could do the same trick, add
those two generators together,
and the result would be
something that was shorter
than at least one of the
component generators.
But here are my starting
times, here,
here, here, and here.
They're all different.
So I have no possibility for
combining two and getting a
better starting time.
Similarly, the ending times
are here, here, and here.
They're all different.
So I'm done.
So, that's how you find a
trellis-oriented generator matrix.
And there's a closely associated
theorem, which is
that a generator matrix g is
trellis-oriented if, and only
if, all starting times differ,
all ending terms differ.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What's the definition
of all generators
as short as possible?
PROFESSOR: I'm now making it.
This is really just
motivation.
So this can be my actual
definition of a
trellis-oriented generator
matrix, which
I've proved this theorem.
It's a matrix in which all the
starting times are different,
and all the ending times
are different.
And what I've achieved is
that all generators
are as short as possible.
How would I go about proving
the theorem?
Suppose I have a matrix that's
not in this form.
And I've already proved that I
can shorten the generators.
So if it's not in this form,
it's not trellis-oriented.
The generators are not
as short as possible.
So all I need to do is
prove the other side.
Suppose it is in this form.
Then could I possibly find
shorter generators?
And the proof of that is
basically the following lemma,
that the subcode C, take
any interval kk prime.
So given a trellis-oriented
generating matrix, namely one
that satisfies these conditions,
then the subcode
consisting of all the code words
who have support on this
interval is generated by
the gj in G that have
support in kk prime.
And that's kind of intuitive
and obvious.
On the one hand, it's clear that
any linear combination of
these generators is a code
word in the subcode.
Obviously they all have support
in this interval.
I can't generate anything that
has support outside that
interval by linear
combinations.
So the only question is, can I
possibly get anything that's
in the subcode by combining
with a generator that is
outside this interval?
And again, it's clear that say I
take kk prime to be here, if
all the starting times are
different, and all the ending
times are different, and I start
to add generators that
are outside here, I can't
possibly get cancellation of
the starting time, or I can't
the ending time.
So I'm going to wind up with a
code word which has support
outside the interval.
So, it really is
a simple lemma.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
have the all 0 code word?
PROFESSOR: Excuse me?
AUDIENCE: The all 0 word will
be part of the subcode.
PROFESSOR: The all 0 word is
always part of the subcode.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
who has something outside
this interval.
Then when you add that with the
all 0 one, you would get
something that does not belong
to the subcode, [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right, but
I have to ask if
there's any code word.
So I have to consider all
the code words, really.
But I'm saying if I have a code
word C that is sum of the
generators, and I have a nonzero
coefficient here on
any generator that has starting
time outside this
interval or ending time outside
this interval, then I
can't possibly get
cancellation of
that nonzero thing.
And so if it really requires
this to be nonzero, and then
I'm going to say that
I get a code word
that's not in this subcode.
So that's very quick, intuitive
sketch of that proof.
Again, for writing it
out, see the notes.
But this lemma then proves this
theorem, because it now
says I can't --
if all the starting times are
different, and all the ending
times are different, then I
can't possibly get shorter
support for any of
the generators.
And I don't think so in a
totally convincing way, but
that basically is
the point here.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, now
I'm defining this.
So, meaning that all the
starting times are different,
and all the ending times
are different.
From now on that's going to
be my definition of a
trellis-oriented generator
matrix.
So, saying that this property
implies this property.
But now this lemma has an
interesting consequence.
This implies for any past and
future, Cp is generated by the
generators in a trellis-oriented
generating
matrix with support in p.
And similarly, Cf is generated
by the generators
with support in f.
So for any p and f, I get a
picture that looks like this.
I can draw now this boundary
anywhere I want, and if the
matrix was trellis-oriented,
then I'm going to get a
certain subset of generators
that live in the past, and
they'll be the generators
in fact of Cp.
The dimension of them will
simply be the number of
generators that live in
the past for that
definition of the past.
There will be some other
set that live
entirely in the future.
Those will be the ones that
generate the future.
And the ones that are neither
wholly in the past or in the
future will generate
the state code.
So that says I can read off the
dimensions of the state
spaces just by looking at this
single trellis-oriented
generator matrix.
So now let me very quickly go
through the calculation that I
went through a little bit
laboriously over here.
Suppose I make the whole
thing the future.
In other words, I draw
a cut before time 0.
Then the state space
has dimension 0.
All four generators live
on the future.
If I make the cut here, the
state space has dimension 1,
because three of the generators
live on the future.
One is active at time 1.
So that means I'm going to get a
two-state trellis at time 1.
If I make the cut here between
past and future, I see two
generators live on the future
and are inactive, haven't
started yet.
But two of the generators
have already started.
At this time we have three
active generators.
Only one is still completely
on the future.
At this time in the middle I
have two generators which --
past subcode, future subcode,
and two that aren't.
So I get this form that we
looked at over there.
And I get a state space here
generated by these two
generators of size two.
So just by looking at this I go
right through the picture,
and I find the size of the
state space at each time.
So this is an algebraic way of
finding the minimal state.
So now I can draw from this a
trellis just by writing down
these state spaces.
Let me leave these
trellises here.
Let me draw now a full
trellis, or an
eight-section trellis.
I'm only going to put one
bit on each trellis.
Here is the starting
state, dimension 0.
One state.
From that I can go
out to 0 or 1.
I won't label the
state spaces.
Next time, I'm still
just branching.
Actually, to make it look like
that, I'm going to want to
come down here, 0,
1, 1, 1, 1, 0.
I basically just have four
states at time two
corresponding to whatever
the first two bits are.
They all go to different states,
because all these have
possible future continuations.
Then I have eight
states at this
time, still just branching.
Sorry, this is going to take
some time to do correctly.
Add this time, then
I come in here.
0, 1.
Anyway, and it's symmetrical
on the other side.
So that's what a full trellis
will look like.
And how did I do this trellis
in principle?
I wrote down all
16 code words.
I wrote down what linear
combinations they were up
here, and I therefore found what
states they went through
at each time.
And then I just drew the graph
that goes through that
describes those trajectories.
So I wrote down all
the code words.
I wrote down all these state
codes at all these times.
I could have written them
down in any order.
And then I just connected
the dots according
to which state --
I make this calculation as to
which state they go through.
That's a good place to stop.
Let me summarize.
We now have a method, given a
generator matrix for a binary
linear block code, of reducing
that generator matrix to
trellis-oriented form.
Just by inspection of the
trellis-oriented generator
matrix, we can determine what
the state space dimensions are
at each instant of time, at
each possible state cut.
And we can then draw a trellis
which achieves that minimal
state space dimension, or
minimal state space size, for
every moment of time
simultaneously.
And I assert that this trellis
is the minimal trellis in
every respect, whether you're
trying to minimize state
complexity, or if you're using
the Viterbi algorithm.
Really what you want to minimize
is the number of
branches, but there's a
calculation about branch
spaces in the notes that shows
that this also achieves the
minimal branch space size at
every time, regardless of how
you draw the trellis.
More elaborate calculations with
a more refined notion of
Viterbi algorithm complexities
still come up
with the same result.
The result is there is
essentially a unique minimal
trellis, where it's minimal
in every way.
And this comes from the linear,
or more broadly, the
group property of the code.
So for any linear group code,
there's a well-defined,
essentially unique up to
re-labeling, minimal trellis
that achieves the minimum of
whatever complexity quantity
you want to define.
So in this sense, the trellis
complexity of a group or
linear code is very
well-defined.
It's defined by this minimal
trellis, or by its parameters,
and we can use that as a measure
of the complexity of
the corresponding group code.
And from an engineering point
of view, once we've got this
minimal trellis, we can use the
Viterbi algorithm to do
maximum likelihood decoding.
Just in the same way we did for
convolutional codes, sweep
from the starting node
to the ending node.
Digest that, and we'll come back
and talk about it again.
Do a few more details
on Monday, but
that's the basic idea.